I play Rafi on the league which is a
show that's all about fantasy football
and my character knows nothing about
football that is because I myself know
nothing about football but what I'm
deciding now to do is what Rafi's
version of football would be because I
think that would be much more enjoyable
game first of all more women players and
also no shirts at all
still helmets because guys you know it's
dangerous the game's name
Rafi would want more glitters like a sky
full of blips each blimp snipers I think
it would be great too if the players
themselves were armed definitely people
need to be able to shoot the blimps out
of the sky I've decided that now every
game needs to have at least one
Hindenburg ask situation while the blimp
is going down the entire crowd
collectively is going oh the humanity
oh the humanity mostly the injuries that
occurred football now of broken legs and
concussions snooze right boring maybe
there's like parts of the field that you
can run over them they're false and it's
like just a vat of like hot water or hot
oil I think that would be good I think
Rafi would enjoy that
maybe there's Tigers that get released
at certain points and I think they
should be weird animals I'm now I'm now
gonna take away the Tigers so you can
erase the Tigers like a lot of people
don't know kangaroos are very dangerous
you know so like maybe like rabid
kangaroos rabid animals and then just
like real stealthily put like a starving
cheetah you know like a really
malnourished cheetah but still fast
really fast there needs to be some sort
of supreme person that this is all for
the pleasure of we can decide who that
is maybe it's President Obama because
he's the president of the country maybe
it's Roger Goodell because he's the king
of NFL and it's a thumbs up thumbs down
you know and then the losers are loaded
onto a blimp and crashed into the ocean
I think that'd be an interesting game
I'd watch that